Hey, what's up guys! In this video
I'm gonna give you seven tips to
increase your testosterone levels naturally
Why is it important to keep your testosterone levels high? Well testosterone is very
important for your overall health and
well-being. If you have low testosterone
levels you might experience low
self-esteem, lack of energy, low sex drive
depression, weight gain, moodiness, thinner bones, and thinner hair. Now testosterone
is that hormone that helps us to go
through puberty. You know to get that
stronger voice, it helps us to grow hair
in a lot of areas... you know to become a
man. But as we get older the testosterone
goes down. It declines. Now most people
believe that it is only important for
guys, but guess what! It also plays a role
in the health and sexual well-being of
women. Alright so how do you increase
your testosterone levels? Well let's
start with the first one:
get enough sleep
If you don't sleep enough your
testosterone levels drop. A study from the
University of Chicago showed that even
if you get five hours of sleep you will
still have 15% lower the testosterone than
if you slept around seven or eight hours
Lose weight
Research shows that obese
men have lower testosterone levels. How
much lower? Well one study in the journal
Clinical Endocrinology showed that some
of obese men have up to 50% less the
testosterone than men who are not
overweight. On the other side if your
body fat percentage is too low it's not
good either because it also causes you
to have lower testosterone. So just be
healthy. Not too fat, not to thin... can I
say that (don't want to hurt anyone's feelings)
Exercise and lifting weights
Working out a few days a week is very
very good for you in so many ways that
you're not even aware of like preventing
many lifestyle diseases but it is also
good for boosting your to testosterone.
Resistance training is the best type of
exercise to boost your testosterone for not only the short term but also for the
long term and taking caffeine before
you're working out can also boost it
even more. That's one of the reasons why I love coffee so much.
Vitamins and supplements
Now studies show that
vitamin D and also zinc boost you're
testosterone the most. So get in the Sun
more for that vitamin D or you can also
get the natural vitamin D from Nordic
and the zinc from garden of life
Like always I have added the direct links for you in a video description down below so
you can go and check it out.
Maintain a balanced diet. Your testosterone levels
also depends a lot on what you are
eating
If you overeat or constantly change your
diet plan it can disrupt your
testosterone levels and you don't want that so you need to maintain a healthy diet
of protein, fat, and carbs. It'll keep your testosterone level high and also
improve your long-term health.
Try to minimize your stress levels
Man! Stress influences so many things of your body, especially your testosterone
levels. Stress causes your hormone
cortisol to raise and when that happens
your testosterone level lowers. So when
the one goes up the other one goes down
and vice versa. This is very important
because most people today have a lot of
stress and studies show that 44% people
say that over the last five years their
stress increased a lot. The biggest
reason why you might stress so much is
because you are worrying constantly
about things that you cannot control.
You need to let go... Remember one of the
strongest weapons against stress is your
ability to choose one thought over
another
The next tip is very important
so listen up: Especially you young guys
out there. Stop using drugs and alcohol
Ah Daniel but it's so cool. It's so much fun. Is it really? It also destroys millions
of lives and it tears up families
I know from personal experience because
my brother used to sell drugs and it
cost him his life.
my uncle used to drink a lot and he was
a bum on the street and there was
nothing we can do for him. I used to
drink a lot myself when I was younger. I
stopped and it changed my life. Now does
it lower your testosterone? Yes of course
it does. According to studies the
National Institute of Alcohol Abuse and
Alcoholism it affects the glands of
hormones involved in male reproductive
health and it lowers the testosterone by
its effect on your body causing hormonal
reactions and cell damage. Now if you're
new here on my channel check out one of
these videos you might like it. You might
find it interesting. If you liked this
one give it a thumbs up subscribe and we
will talk soon. Cheers!